[Music]
jalen starts off this hour in atlanta
georgia hi jalen what's up
hi sir thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
yes sir so i just actually learned about
the baby steps and all that you've done
starting in january but
in december i made the stupid maybe
smart decision uh i ordered a tesla
model y and learning that it's 60 000
and that will put me in debt i turned
around as like okay that may not be the
best idea but then i came up with the
idea of doing research that i could
generate into passive income by renting
on suro and allowing others to you know
drive do have a rental property
essentially for the vehicle and make
that income back and paying off the debt
with that
however i'd still be risking having that
debt because if things happen and i'm
not able to rent the car out and things
like that i could still be withheld i'm
paying almost at 900
monthly car note so i just wanted to
know if that's a good idea i'm 23 i'm
single i don't have any other debt
except for my current car which is my
kso but it's currently on positive
equity and i'm just continuing paying
that off learning from the baby steps so
just really want some advice with this
all right there's a lot going on here
jalen but i'm glad you found us it's
interesting dave they always find you
right after they do a dumb thing and
then a month later they're going i found
dave
it's amazing but let me let me answer
your question so you've got dead on the
key of soul and you're going i got a
business making opportunity by getting a
sweet toy and letting someone else
destroy it while i slowly painfully pay
back the debt on two cars now that's a
different way than he said it george
you're right that's the way i heard it
i'll say that jalen so no
do not get this tesla you need to pay
off this kia soul and if you do ever get
a tesla i want you to do with cash how
much money do you make
so i just got a promotion actually in
january as well so i'm currently going
to be at 60 000 plus incentives you said
60 000
yes so you're gonna own a sixty thousand
dollar car making sixty thousand dollars
a year
when you put it that way it sounds even
worse okay
that's why he did that that's why he did
it
he's completely messing with you but
he's doing he's doing it because he
loves you i love you and i want you to
win financially and the turo tesla deal
is not going to be the business model
you you think yes so jalen um here's the
thing you really good question and i
really appreciate you calling sir
um a good way to make some of these
decisions
is to uh pan way back
and say okay when i'm 35
12 years from now
which will be the best decision
and it kind of instantly leads you to
not doing the tesla thing and getting
the car paid off and starting to build
some wealth doesn't it
right but
the tesla only sounds good when you
think about taking delivery on it it
doesn't sound good when you're 35 you
have a 35 you have 12 year old battery
at that point with some wheels
right right and with my current car now
since i can get more than what it's
worth paying off the
the loan should i
what is the balance of the car that i
have what's the balance so i owe
fourteen thousand cars numbers offering
the seventeen no just pay it off just
just work yourself you got a job just
work work your way out of it and then if
you wanna trade cars do it with cash
later but let's just you have a small
car debt
making fifty thousand sixty thousand and
let's turn around and get it paid off as
quick as we can um because again so the
other thing i always ask myself is what
and and i went broke when i was 28
lost everything because i was stupid
so one of the things i started doing at
that point i started talking to old rich
people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him he was stupid i
want to talk to old people who had money
made it and kept it
okay
and and then i've continued that for the
last 30 years that discussion with old
rich people to the point we did a
detailed in-depth research of the
largest research
study ever done on millionaires in north
america
and the number of millionaires out of
the 10 000 millionaires that we studied
the number of of them that said they
became a millionaire because they went
in debt to buy their car so they could
rent it out was precisely zero
none of them used your plan that you
presented to us a while ago
and so
you know and and because it's it's it's
just fraught with disaster there's so
many things that can go wrong in that
plan
that you laid out there
and um
you know if you've ever had a rental
property or ever put a property out as
an airbnb
you would know not to put your car out
in that system because people just don't
take care of it
people are gross as a matter of fact
they're just gross they're filthy
animals
and so you really find that out about
them when they live in stuff or will
drive stuff that you own
and it's just you're gonna discover that
with your sixty thousand dollar car with
your sixty thousand dollar income so
please don't do it i think you're not
going to i think we talked you out of it
but just for the other people listening
that are thinking the same way i want to
make sure we
drive the stake deeply into the ground
on that so
yeah pan back
ask yourself
what would old rich people do
because that's what you want to be
rich
when you're old
and dave when it comes to spending
decisions i like to think of it through
a framework where i go okay is this let
me have some self-awareness is this
gonna add value to my life is it born
out of my values and i move on to
motivation and this is where it gets
really tough especially for young people
what's my motive do i have a good motive
in buying this thing am i trying to flex
on my friends do i want a shiny cool toy
so i feel successful and then i go into
affordability and i go can i afford this
in cash and if america answered that
correctly no one would be in debt would
they
then you go into research mode and go is
this the best price retailer option that
i can get and then you go into timing
and you go all right is this the right
time to buy this what's the opportunity
cost could i wait a year could i wait
three years and when you do that it
actually spells smart which is really
cute
but what it does it helps you just take
a pause and think through a framework to
go
is this the right decision for where i'm
at financially and if you answer no to
any of those here's what it means not
now we're not saying we never want you
to have nice stuff i want you to drive a
model why tesla one day jalen but i want
you to do it when you get your income up
you can pay cash for this thing it's a
small portion of your life in your world
and you're not doing it to flex on other
people and you've done it because you're
already out of debt and you're investing
that that changes the game
you know i
very few
there's so many people we're a car
culture
uh and cars until the last 18 months go
down in value and they will again as
soon as this little supply demand curve
thing quits
they will depreciate again
and so it's the largest thing we buy
that goes down in value and once you've
gotten past transportation to take your
family somewhere or to take yourself to
work once you've gotten past that the
car is no longer a need everything above
basic transportation is a want
and sadly in my life when i was young
before i was 30 years old
it was we didn't call it flexing but
it's just trying to impress other people
trying to keep up with the joneses
trying to make somebody think i bought a
jaguar them so that people would think i
was successful yeah based on the car you
drive
that's your measure but that's what
people do and i was that shallow i was
that dumb
jalen's not that dumb no